les décombres d'une école acadie fca
dans la république autoproclamée de
louhansk contrôlée par les séparatistes
pro-russes les autorités affirment que
les forces du craignent n ont détruit
une grande partie du bâtiment
à minuit l'armée ukrainienne a bombardé
l'école le gymnase a été complètement
détruit et les salles de classe
endommagés
il est impossible de suivre les cours
tout l'équipement est détruit
c'était bruyant effrayant
sera une victoire pour moi surtout
d'après les séparatistes les forces du
craignait n'ont bombardé la ville avec
des lance-roquettes times have fournis
par les états unis pendant ce temps à
près de 75 km de là les troupes du
craignait non déclaré avoir repris le
village de bil'in orif cas qui se trouve
à moins de 20 km de licite chance qu
tombée aux mains des russes en juillet
dernier cette vidéo amateur partagés sur
télégrammes montrent selon ses auteurs
des soldats d'ukrainiens patrouillant
dans une cause du village
la reconquête de ces zones serait une
nouvelle avancée symbolique pour kiev de
leur côté les dirigeants pro russe de
loups ans ainsi que de la région de
donetsk ont appelé à l'organisation de
référendums sur leur attachement à la
russie
les habitants du dombass ont fait leur
choix en 2014 nous avons attendu espéré
toutes ces années qu'un second
référendum arrive et réalise notre rêve
de revenir chez nous en russie
des appels lancés alors que les combats
semblent se rapprocher de ces localités
kiev affirme que son armée prête à
reprendre la totalité de la région de
lougansk